peut-être
[Musique]
m
je
enfin
ça va
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez bien vous voulez bien que
vous voulez bien je vous raconte une
histoire drôle à un bon cv elle est
vraiment drôle
je suis bien content que ce soit à moi
de ponnat parle parce que depuis que je
sais que que je vais vous raconter cette
histoire drôle je ris je me reconnais un
jeu pourtant pas davantage
je m'excuse
il faut que je vous la raconte voilà
c'est c'est l'histoire des bleus c'est
l'histoire du du jockey vous riez déjà
avant de la connaître
qu'est ce que ça va être quand vous la
connaissez l'histoire du jockey qui
entre dans la salle de bain
avant d'aller plus loin il faut que je
vous dise ce qui est arrivé à mon copain
qui l'a raconté cette histoire drôle
pour que vous prenez vos précautions
vous allez comprendre après un un jour
mon copain qui qui racontait cette
histoire drôle
un jour il va dans un café où il avait
l'habitude d'aller mais ce jour là
y'avait personne n'y a pas de clients il
y avait juste la servante l'écrit qui
servait arrière elle lui dit alors quoi
de neuf
bah je lui dis rien c'est tout ce que
vous racontez aurait dit oui en gros
c'est tout puis se ravise il dit
maintenant que je raconte une histoire
drôle
ah oui j'ai fait le petit oui elles sont
21 oui alors il y raconte l'histoire que
je lève ragondins
ce temps dans nos rues il lui dit comme
ça c'est l'histoire du du jockey le
jockey café le petit joker à comprendre
tout et je dois arrêter c'est rencontres
francophones voulaient pas rater
d'ailleurs il m'a dit enfin madame vous
avez vous lu à quand on a mis ça en
route c'est comme tout il fallait
jusqu'au bout alors je lui dis c'est ce
jeu clé qui ont d'ensablement
voilà des poulets je touche je vous
allez me faire mourir
ce à quoi elle croyait pas si bien dire
qu'elle est morte
au complet il est embêté 1
je sais que c'est une histoire à mourir
de rire makamba il intervient au
commissariat hélas le commissaire l'a
interrogé un jeune lui a dit comme ça
alors comment l'avez-vous tué la petite
un bon copain lige de protéger raconte
une histoire drôle ouais
une histoire dont qui fait comme ça
sceptique parce qu'il était sceptique
commissaire sceptiques toujours
sceptiques
d'ailleurs dans son entourage tous ses
collègues et ils l'appelaient ses tics
sais pas pourquoi d'ailleurs son vrai
nom c'était la fosse
il est évident ça raconte une histoire
en mai raconté à nous livrer aux mots
coup de vieux aux non monsieur
commissaire si je manque d'entrain dans
le même temps travail un droit en
costume du sauveur dont le stock est
avec le comici accueilli fait voulez que
je vous en donne moi de lens 1 1
c'était un sentimental à mon coach bayat
influençable une des bombes a plus que
vous me le demandez gentiment je voulais
raconter mon histoire
alors il la raconte l'histoire de que je
vais le voir grandir et vivre l'histoire
du d'usure que qui en deçà de haut du
belgo usa arrêté je ne regarde pas comme
une fois qu'on rigole au commissariat
sans consulter les autres passent bien
et pourquoi pouvoir revenir à ce moment
là il a poussé ce cri
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le grand costaud il est mort que lui
joue après bastien il n'avait pas
compris tout de suite
le times ont repeint ils étaient embêtés
on sait en prison tout seul dans sa
cellule il se faisait du mauvais sang à
tel point qu'il s'est suicidé
il sait raconter son histoire drôle et
il est mort de rire
on a été très douloureux très très parce
que justement à cette époque là il avait
les lèvres gercées penny a fini
enfin je vous ai dit tout ça pour que
vous preniez vos précautions parce que
comme je vais vous la raconter mon
histoire je ne voudrais pas être
responsables de plusieurs victimes comme
l'a été mon copain bac à je vous l'a dit
et si à un moment vous ne vous sentez
pas bien
vous sortez les gars je la connais c'est
pour ça c'est l'histoire du genre
commence du début à
comme j'étais interrompu ça pourrait
vous paraître un peu décousu ce bac je
recommence c'est l'histoire du jour
qu'est ce qu'ils ont en eux
et c'est que
il sortira sortira nous sentir à
rechercher merci et bien notre ami
bourvil vient de nous raconter si l'on
veut une de ces histoires mais je vous
raconte la femme ont certes banon
[Musique]